por supuesto sigue
preguntándose la importancia de la
prevención de este tipo de hechos pero
también consternación por el crimen del
diputado amish uno de los diputados en
el parlamento británico con más
experiencia casi 40 años como miembro de
la cámara de los comunes resaltó el
primer ministro que además uno de los
diputados que más leyes había aprobado
en este país y entretanto sigue esa
reflexión ese debate sobre si los
diputados británicos
deben y necesitan seguridad la ministra
del interior crítica que él dejó abierta
la posibilidad de que los diputados
cuando hagan estas reuniones con sus
electores no en londres sino en sus
regiones puedan tener acompañamiento de
la policía y de las autoridades